leurs invités qui accompagne la première
dame à z on peut peut-être dire un mot
il y aura l'ambassadrice de l'ukraine
aux états unis il y aura la lanceuse
d'alert de facebook 26 à horgen et
plusieurs autres invités
oui absolument anne-marie évidemment
l'ambassadrice ukrainienne c'est très
symbolique l'appui que savez-vous nous
sommes sur l'avenue pennsylvania qui
allaient dans le drapeau ukrainien la de
la maison blanche vers le capitole il ya
le drapeau ukrainien et américains qui
longe toute la rue donc vraiment les
états unis sont avec l'ukraine ce soir
il ya également celles que joe biden a
nommé là pour comme juge de la cour
suprême elle va également être là six
des neuf juges de la cour suprême seront
également présents mais c'est un
discours vraiment qui va parler de
l'ukraine il va évidemment être question
de l'économie cv la question que tous
les américains se poser la question à
laquelle joe biden doit répondre c est
ce que les américains se porte mieux
aujourd'hui par rapport il ya un an donc
évidemment avec ce taux d'inflation à
s'élever également une hausse de la
criminalité aux états unis joe biden
devra répondre à ces questions là il va
essayer évidemment de parler de ces
acquis sur l'infrastructure par exemple
ce projet de loi qu'il a réussi à faire
passer au congrès l'état des routes on
parle de plus de 100000 km de routes qui
doivent être réparés 1500 pont qui va
également certainement parler des
réformes sociales de son flanc berne
bakbasel d'économie évidemment il a
essayé de dire bon écoutez depuis que je
suis là il ya énormément de création
d'emplois mais les américains bon la
guerre en ukraine oui c'est important
mais pour eux c'est ce qui se passe dans
leur portefeuille quand ils vont faire
leurs courses le coût de la vie qui a
énormément augmenté le coût de l'essence
dans toutes ces questions là il doit
rassurer la procurer de la guerre en
ukraine pourrait avoir un impact même
sur le taux d'inflation c'est tout le
monde entier va ressentir les
répercussions assez remercier d'être là
on voit l'entrée au petit à petit des
membres du gouvernement du cabinet dans
les rangs de vue anthony blinken
notamment les gens les invités
arrive un après l'autre ça réunit les
représentants du congrès le sénat les
invités je vais parler à mes autres
invités s'ils voulaient bien à z vous
restez avec nous très rapidement voir un
peu ce qu'ils attendent de ce discours
ce soir d'abord vous monsieur marié
quelles sont vos attentes le président
qui s'occupe de l'aide le du niveau de
vie des américains le commandant en chef
qu'est-ce que ça mais je pense que je
pense que c'est votre bille mis la table
ça va être un discours qui va porter sur
la situation internationale qui est très
très très sérieuse et savate un discours
dans lequel sur le plan intérieur de
politique intérieure monsieur ben ali va
chercher à améliorer son statut son
soutien politique en parlera de ses
réalisations et en mettant l'accent sur
peut-être que maintenant il va s'occuper
plus activement de l'inflation quoique
je veux pas très bien ce qui va faire
deux premiers points le premier à
première cible il va très écouté par les
élites et son discours en aura peut-être
des effets la deuxième celle de celle de
ses soutiens populaires ou impopulaire
aux états unis je pense pas qu'ils
réussissent beaucoup a changé la donne
de l'opinion publique en effet quand on
regarde les derniers sondages notamment
de facto des aides valérie beaudouin
l'approbation générale est assez faibles
on dit que c'est presqu'un record même
président est aussi impopulaire après
une année d'administration avec un taux
de seulement 41 % taux de désapprobation
qui frôle les 40 4% et c'est sur la
coved 1 il ya une petite majorité 51%
mais sur l'inflation c'est 30% valérie
boudier vous quelles sont vos attentes
ce soir mes attentes sont un peu les
mêmes que mon collègue juste avant
vraiment la question internationale
parce que ça va être regardé aux états
unis donc justement pour augmenter cette
cote de popularité qui est vraiment pas
très bonne la pire cote était celle de
josh homme et john dryden suit de près
mais il ya aussi ce discours qui serait
écoutée à l'international par ce qui se
passe encore de l'action en ukraine en
ce moment et on va surveiller ça de près
on peut imaginer qu'on a même modifié le
disco jusque dans les dernières minutes
avant avance est ce discours que ce soit
prononcée parce qu'il était prêt depuis
plusieurs semaines mais la situation
bien sûr changé j'ai hâte de voir s'ils
veulent ça va envoyer leurs messages et
julien tourreille un extrait qu'on a
révélée tout à l'heure c'est monsieur
gbagbo on va dire poutine avec thor nous
étions prêts et j'ajouterai à voir d'où
la parole julien qu'on apprend que
boeing suspens tout soutien opérationnel
aux compagnies aériennes russes alors
c'est une grosse décision et les etats
unis ont annoncé il ya quelques heures à
peine la fermeture de l'espace aérien
aux avions russes en fait on a peut-être
perdu de nouvelles en cours de route
qu'on pensait peut-être que c'était déjà
fait mais il arrive ce etats-unis
arrivent après après le canada d'après
l'union européenne et après le
royaume-uni julien alors vous atteindre
vous ce soir sans surprise mais a
tendance à être essentiellement sur sa
capacité à joe biden à se présenter
comme le commandant en chef d'une nation
non pas qui est directement en guerre
mais qui est à la tête d'un effort
international pour mener cette
opposition à vladimir poutine il faut
pas oublier que lorsqu'il est arrivé à
la présidence joe biden il voulait d'une
part réunifier le pays apaisé le débat
politique au etats unis et d'autre part
il voulait montrer que les états unis
étaient de retour sur la scène
internationale en prenant la tête de
cette coalition des démocraties qu'il
appelait de ses voeux pour lutter contre
des régimes autoritaires qui est qu'ils
sont sur la voie donc il était sur la
voie ascendante on se souvient il ya
quelques semaines il a organisé un
sommet de la micra si virtuelle à
washington qui a pas eu un grand écho
évidemment la situation en ukraine et la
réaction de la communauté en particulier
occidental à celle ci montre que joe
biden peut aspirer à jouer ce rôle de
leader l'opinion publique américaine ne
semble pas trop au courant de ça en tout
cas dans les sondages il ne bénéficie
pas encore d'un phénomène de ralliement
autour du drapeau ça serait peut-être ce
soir une bonne occasion de se présenter
notamment comme un président en temps de
crise internationale en un président
entend guère vous parlez de drapeaux 112
drapeau américain on peut voir que les
démocrates porte à la boutonnière le
drapeau ukrainien donc
daniel marien un président à quelques
mois d'une élection de mi-mandat doit
séduire son électorat essayer de
retrouver la faveur lors de ce bail
données très impopulaire en ce moment il
va voir un jeu d'équilibré à faire
j'imagine entre la vie enfin la
politique intérieure des états unis et
ce qu'il doit jouer comme rôle aux yeux
du monde
ça m'étonnerait pas qu'il cherche à se
présenter je te veux comme je veux
intervenants comme un président à temps
de presse que gains pour essayer
d'enclencher le phénomène de radio vers
le président qui se produit quand les
états unis entrent en guerre ou d'autres
pays quand il entre en gare ou sur la
situation majeur de crise mais je pense
qu'il va peut-être essayer de faire ça
mais ça m'étonnerait que ça
fonctionnerait bouka fonctionnerait
beaucoup parce que le pays est tellement
divisée et chez les républiques et la
base le terrain tu te retires impliquée
dans des tests byden merveille le
déteste qu'on ya des gens qui rentrent
dans mes cours avec des t-shirts qui
disait l'escaut brandon ce qui est
étonnant deux erreurs f ben alors il ya
tellement de passion contre bayonne chez
cet électorat là et je suis pas certain
que l'électorat démocrate sera très très
susceptibles d'être rallye l'idée de
personne
la présentation d'un chef sur enter
detry ça m'étonnerait le plus bas à la
baleine arrive dans l'hémicycle alors on
va voir son accueil et je vous invite à
commenter
invités si vous voulez ce que vous voyez
les gens que vous voyez il est bien
accueilli bien sûr par les démocrates et
vous voyez bien le drapeau ukrainien le
pilote petit plus il est
on attendait beaucoup de lui mais avec
ce que monsieur m'a rien de bien nous
dire valérie beaudouin leur trompe est
loin d'être finie parce qu'il y ait des
républicains ce soir tu ne sont pas là
parce qu'il refuse de passer le test de
l'aco vide c'est une mesure salutaire
qui est exigé oui il y en a aussi qui
fonctionne comme un message politique y
en a qui vont choisir de ne pas se lever
de ne pas applaudir parce que bon leur
trump est peut-être terminée dans un
sens mais dans un autre laura dedans
n'ont trompé toujours au dessus des
républicains on va voir si ça va être
très partisan visuellement parlant
j'aime toujours voir à quel moment on
décide de se rallier au président c'est
lé moment où on va applaudir les moments
un peu de solidarité qui risquent d'être
à et si on voit sur les images aussi
vous parler à la boutonnière les
drapeaux ukrainienne ya aussi des gens
qui ont choisi de porter les couleurs du
drapeau ukrainien des gens qui sont
habillés de jaune ou de bleu c'est aussi
un message politique très très fort
justement pour le peuple ukrainien mais
aussi pour l'espèce de solidarité
américaine d'un peuple qui veut faire
face à cette guerre-là qui veut envoyer
un message très fort à vladimir poutine
donc dans la salle et aussi ses messages
politiques là qui vont au delà à mon
avis discours hazib
monsieur baden c'est bien peu paris il
sait qu'il joue gros avec ce discours ce
soient les discours de l'union c'est une
tradition peut-être que le lendemain on
se souvient pas trop de ce que le
président c'est des bons mots beaucoup
d'espoir
on pourrait dire comment les au canada
les voix ensoleillée mais en même temps
cette fois ci est ce que selon vous à z
ce discours prend un caractère
historique parce que justement les temps
tant de presque guerre comme disait
daniel marié
oui absolument elle m'a écouté
normalement un discours de l'eau donnée
sur l'état de l'union ne change pas
grand chose à en général les gens ne se
souviennent à peine d'une phrase dhabi
ce tour mais cette fois ci c'est ça
avait quand même une importance
historique également il paraît que
vladimir poutine va aussi regarder ce
discours voir s'il ya de la division
voir s'il a vraiment le soutien des
républicains souvenez vous dans notre
show n'y a pas si longtemps on disait
que vladimir poutine était un génie et
qu'en fait il disait c'est pas vraiment
qu'il soit un génie mais c'est que l joe
biden et les démocrates sont sont pas
intelligents il a il a vraiment dit ça
lors d'un lors d'un discours il a été
très critiqué dans notre champ pas
encore des gens qui le soutiennent
énormément états unis les etats-unis
restent encore aujourd'hui extrêmement
divisé la donc joe biden a aussi
évidemment le devoir de rassembler tous
les américains ou peut-être que la
guerre en ukraine va lever les genoux
fait davantage alors évidemment derrière
le président wade non voilà
vice-présidente camel arioui sa
présidente sheila et c'est du congrès
nancy pelosi deux alliés des mains du
président on va l'écouter puis on se
retrouve tout de suite après pour
décrypter ce discours de l'état de
l'union le premier de dubaï dont on est
où là
un qui aura 20
jours merci merci
s'il vous plaît
je remercie infiniment
madame la présidente
madame la vice présidence
gentil
congressistes juge de la cour suprême
mes chers compatriotes
l'année dernière
la pandémie nous a dit viser cette année
nous sommes finalement ensemble à
nouveau
oui mais ce soir nous rencontrons entre
indépendants démocrates
et républicains mais avant tout comme
américain avec un devant surtout vers
l'amérique le peuple américain et la
constitution et une détermination
indéfectible que la liberté va toujours
triomphé sur la tyrannie
sexton il ya ces jours
là des meilleures poutines a tenté
d'ébranler les fondations de l'occident
pensant qu'il pourrait faire infléchir
l'occident mais il a vraiment fait une
erreur de calcul grève ils pensaient
qu'ils pouvaient entrer comme ça à la
bonne franquette on lutte crème mais il
ne s'attendait jamais à cette muraille
il a rencontré pour la première fois le
peuple ukrainien
et le président alain ski
chaque l'ukrainien chaque ukrainienne
quand je vois leur vaillance le courage
leur détermination et bien ce qu'inspire
le monde entier des groupes de citoyens
qui bloque les chars d'assaut avec leur
propre corps des étudiants des aînés des
enseignants qui sont devenus soldats à
défendre leur patrie et dans cette
bataille
monsieur années ce qui a dit au
parlement européen la lumière gagne sur
les ténèbres et l'ambassadeur et
craignait est parmi nous avec la
première dame
si vous êtes en mesure de vous lever
envoyer un signal au monde entier
merci merci madame merci de votre
présence parmi nous merci encore
les
vaillantes courageuse déterminée
[Applaudissements]
nous les etats-unis d'amérique sommes du
côté j'ai pas plus craignait tout au
long cette histoire nous avons appris
cette leçon quand les dictateurs ' je ne
paient pas le prix de régulation ils
causent encore plus à marcher il
continue de rouler et les coûts les
menaces pour l'amérique et pour le monde
ainsi nos font qu'augmenter c'est
pourquoi l'alliance de l'otan est écrit
afin d'assurer la stabilité la paix en
europe après la seconde guerre mondiale
les états unis sont un membre de concert
avec vingt neuf autres pays et cela
compte pour quelque chose la diplomatie
compte pour quelque chose la
détermination américaine compte pour
quelque chose la dernière attaque de
poutine contre l'ukraine était
préméditée et complètement non
provoquées il a rejeté de nombreux
efforts de diplomatie il pensait que
l'occident et le temps ne réagirais pas
ils pensaient qu'ils pouvaient nous
diviser nous aidez nous crie vie ici
chez nous il pensait qu' il pouvait
aussi divisé l'europe mais il a fait une
erreur nous sommes prêts nous sommes
unis et voilà c'est que nous avons fait
nous sommes restés unis nous sommes
préparés et avec beaucoup de soin nous
avons passé des mois à
former des coalitions
avec le camp saint fris qu'est
asiatiques pour affronter pour ses nus
comme beaucoup d'entre vous j'ai passé
lui d'innombrables heures avec mes
homologues européens nous partagions
avec le monde entier ce que qualifiait
monsieur poutine et comment il voulait
justement justifié par de fausses
assertions sur le tac on a donc affronté
cela avec la vérité et maintenant qu'il
a agi il a pas ou geste le monde
l'hébreu le terreau de wable de concert
avec 27 membres de l'union européenne et
que la france l'allemagne l'italie tout
comme des pays tels que le royaume uni
le canada le japon la corée l'australie
la nouvelle-zélande et bientôt quand
même avec la suisse imaginez sont en
train défi j la douleur sur la russie
poutine isolé du monde entier plus que
jamais
jarrett ensemble de concert avec nos
alliés nous sommes en train d'appliquer
des sanctions puissante le coupon les
banques cèdent importante de la russie
nous empêchons la banque centrale de
défendre le rouble russe pour que les
630 milliards de dollars dans sa réserve
d'urgence
inopérant nous sommes en train
d'étouffer leur accès à la technologie
et nous allons ainsi affaiblir son
appareil militaire pendant les années à
venir ce soir jeudi aux oligarques
russes et aux corrompus et qu'ils ont
volé des milliards aux russes c'est fini
ça suffit
et je suis sérieux
les états unis
le ministère de la justice est un trait
de constituer un groupe pour aller
chercher justement ces oligarques et
toutes les activités criminelles de
concert avec les élites européennes nous
allons saisir lors appartements de luxe
le réactiver leur bateau de croisière
nous allons saisir ses biens il est cédé
ce soir annonce que nous allons le
joindre aux alliés en ferment l'espace
aérien à tous les vols russes c'est fini
une autre
partie de cette pression que l'on exerce
sur la russie
il n'a aucune idée de ce qui l'attend le
rouble a déjà perdu 30% de sa valeur
40% de valeur boursière perdue et la
bourse est toujours fermé l'économie
russe est entré de chanceler et pouls de
ses nus est le seul qui est responsable
de concert avec nos alliés nous offrons
du sud sait où se craignaient dans leur
combat pour la liberté de l'aide
militaire de l'aide économique de l'est
des humanitaires nous offrons plus d'un
milliard de dollars d aides directes
pour l'ukraine et nous allons continuer
d'aider le peuple ukrainien à mesure
qu'ils défendent la patrie et vous
alléger leurs souffrances
bonjour mais les crues mais
permettez-moi peu de clarté nous force
militaire ne vont pas s'engager dans un
conflit avec les armées russes nous
n'allons pas en europe pour eux nous
battre sur le terrain et craignait mais
pour défendre l'otan s'est jamais
poutine ses cartes c'est pourquoi en
mobiliser toutes nos forces le
déploiement aérien maritime pour
protéger tout le flanc est de l'otan et
comme je dis très clairement les états
unis et nos alliés vont défendre chaque
centimètre carré de territoire qui
appartient le temps avec toute la force
de la puissance collective chaque
centimètre carré
et nous sommes lucides et craignent
elles résistent avec un courage pure
mais les prochains jours les semaines
voire les mois qui viennent seront
difficiles
poutine a déchaîné le chaos la violence
et les brutalités
mais s'il peut peut-être remporter une
bataille passée par là il va continuer
de payer un prix fort élevé à moyen
terme
et ce peuple si fier sont prêts à tout
donner pour repousser
l'agresseur il qu'ils ont connu trente
ans d'indépendance ils ont montré a
commis deux reprises qu'ils ne vont pas
tolérer quiconque qui veut essayer de
faire reculer leur pays à tous les
américains à tous les américains je vais
être franc avec vous j'ai toujours
promis cela le dictateur russe a envahi
un pays étranger et cela résonne de par
le monde et moi j'agis de façon
vigoureuse pour s'assurer que la douleur
des sanctions vis est l'économie russe
et que nous nous servions de toulouse
outils pour protéger les commerces et
les consommateurs américains ce soir je
puis vous annoncer que nous avons
travaillé avec 30 au pays afin de
libérer
30 milliards de baril pétrole de par le
monde
donc pardon 30 millions de baril de la
réserve de pétrole stratégie qui nous
sommes prêts à libérer davantage unis
avec nos alliés ces étapes vont
certainement aider à mettet les prix
accessibles pour le les sens mais je
sais que ça peut vous alarmer toutes ces
nouvelles mais j'aimerais vous sachiez
que nous allons nous en sortir nous
allons nous en sortir ne craignez rien
quand vous allez écrire l'histoire de
cette époque vous allez voir que poutine
a affaibli la russie et à renforcer le
monde entier
- chauny
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que peut-être cela ne prenait
pas une guerre pour qu'on comprenne
l'enjeu au moins maintenant on comprend
très bien l'enjeu on voit l'unité parmi
les nations une europe plus unie
l'occident plus unifiée nous voyons de
l'unité parmi les gens qui se
rassemblent dans les villes dans
d'énormes foules de par le monde même en
russie pour manifester leur soutien pour
le peuple ukrainien le combattre la
démocratie l'autocratie entre les
démocraties est bien une démocratie sont
à la hauteur du moment et le monde
choisit la paix la sécurité
voilà le vrai test
ça va prendre du temps alors continue de
nous inspirer par cette volonté de faire
des ukrainiens et un nos compatriotes
ukrainien avec tous ces liens qui nous
unissent nous sommes à vos côtés nous
sommes vraiment à vos côtés poutine va
peut-être encerclé kiev avec ses blindés
mais jamais il ne pourra avoir accès au
coeur à l'esprit ukrainien il ne pourra
jamais affaiblir la volonté du monde
libre
nous nous rencontrons ce soir l'amérique
qui a traversé deux des années les plus
difficiles de notre histoire la pandémie
a été vraiment cruel et combien de
familles vivent d'un chèque
de paye à l'autre avec tout l'inflation
convient je comprends comme beaucoup
d'entre vous mon papa a dû quitter ce
coin tine pour trouver du travail
ailleurs donc comme beaucoup d'entre
vous j'ai vraiment compris que quand le
prix de l'eau de l'alimentation montait
savane impact et c'est ce que j'ai fait
au tout début de ma présidence c'est de
vouloir
adopter le plan de sauvetage l'américain
les gens souffraient on agit
peu de lois ont fait davantage un moment
critique de notre histoire pour nous
sortir d'une crise
et quand c'est à toutes ces efforts de
vaccination
on a offert launay les chemins can make
a des dizaines de milliers d'américains
et régler l'épicerie
rappelez-vous toutes ces autos qui
attendaient en file pour une seule boîte
d'une rupture on à diminuer le coût de
l'assurance médicaments lazaros maladie
et comme appât le faisais c'était donner
un petit peu
mangé manoeuvre pas comme l'y millions
de réductions d'impôts de
l'administration
intérieur
le plan de sauvetage l'amérique à aider
les gens de la classe ouvrière et a pas
laissé personne derrière tout le
contraire de la loi promulguée par
l'ansés président que vous connaissez
bien
et ça a fonctionné
cela a fonctionné mesdames et messieurs
nous avons créé des emplois beaucoup de
plans fait notre économie a créé plus de
6.5 millions d'emplois cette année ici
donc plus d'emplois en une seule année
qu'à tout moment dans l'histoire des
états unis d'amérique
économies accrues par 5 7% la croissance
la plus forte en 40 ans est la première
étape pour les changements à l'économie
qui n'avait pas été vraiment à l'écouté
des travailleurs et des travailleuses
depuis trop longtemps depuis quatre ans
on nous a dit que l'allègement dépôt
aurait un effet induit sur tout le monde
mais cette théorie a mené une croissance
affaiblies des salaires plus faibles des
visées plus important et un écart plus
grand entre les richissimes et tous les
autres dans notre société isl à l'écart
le plus important depuis un siècle
écoutez on s'est présentés
madame allo c'est moi et je sais qu'on
est en désaccord là dessus mais on s'est
présenté avec une nouvelle vision
économique pour l'amérique investir ici
et lucky nos compatriotes faire
augmenter la main d'oeuvre et faire
vraiment grandir l'économie de
l'intérieur et non pas de l'extérieur du
bas vers le haut car nous savons fort
bien
car nous savons fort bien que quand la
classe moyenne
grandi
les pauvres peuvent voir une voie vers
le haut et les riches se porte tout
aussi bien on avait les meilleurs
aéroports à une certaine époque et
maintenant nos infrastructures sont tous
très et meurant du monde on pourra pas
être concurrents pour les emplois du
prochain sexy on ne répare pas cela
c'est pourquoi il était tellement
opportun de faire adopter la loi sur les
affreux torture une loi bipartite et
j'aimerais remercier mes collègues
républicains et d'avoir contribué à ce
succès rebâtissons l'amérique
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'investissement le plus important
dans l'histoire notre pays
c'est un effort bipartite et j'aimerais
remercier les deux parties qui ont
travaillé sur ce dossier
pas question de semaines ou d'animer
d'une décennie d'infrastructures
écoutez
cela va transformer l'amérique
pour qu'on soit sur une voie pour gagner
la compétition du 20e siècle surtout
quand on pense à la chine
j'ai dit à monsieur jean ping et cela
n'a jamais été une bonne idée de parier
contre pape d'amérique vous en créer de
bons emplois pour des millions
d'américains on va moderniser les routes
les aéroports les ports les voies d'eau
tout partout en amérique et on va voir
ici également promouvoir la justice
écologique et économique on aura cinq
cent mille postes de recharge pour les
véhicules électriques on va remplacer
tous les tuer ou de plomb pour que tous
les enfants puissent voir de longues
sans plomb dedans
nous avons offrir
de l'internet rapide pour tous les
américains dans les zones rurales dans
les banlieues et même dans les
communautés tribales 4p proches ont déjà
été annoncés beaucoup d'entre vous
avaient renoncé cela dans vos
cette transcription est là j'annonce que
nous allons réparer plus de 65 mille
kilomètres ou 1000 si vous le voulez
l'auto route et 1500 pont qui ont besoin
d'être réparés et mesdames et messieurs
- non lieu quand on se sert de l'argent
des contribuables pour rebâtir
l'amérique
nous allons acheter américain
acheter des produits américains et
soutenez voir créer des emplois en
amérique
le gouvernement fédéral dépense environ
600 milliards par année pour nous
protéger il ya une loi depuis un siècle
qui s'assure que les landais
contribuables soutiennent l'emploi
américain chaque gouvernement dit qu'il
va promulguer cela mais nous le faisons
réellement avec achetez américain en
fait en sorte que tout que ce soit
vraiment
garde-fous sur une autoroute où le pont
des
navires de guerre tout soit fabriqué en
amérique mais vous savez
afin de
gagner les meilleurs emplois de l'avenir
il faut aussi égalisé nos chances avec
la chine et d'autres concurrents c'est
pourquoi il est tellement important de
faire adopter la loi sur l'innovation
bipartite qui est au congrès et nous
pourrons justement investir dans les
technologies émergentes et l'industrie
mairie cani
avant on était à 2 % de pnp dans la
recherche le développement ce n'est plus
le cas
mais la chine oui je vous donne un
exemple pourquoi c'est tellement
important
si vous allez 20 mai la laisse de
columbus en ohio vous allez trouver
mille hectares de terres ville charge
n'a pas l'air de grand chose me regarder
de près cette chan de rêve
c'est là où nous allons construire notre
avenir c'est là qu'une telle cette
entreprise américaine qui a contribué à
sec en valais va construire un méga site
de semi conducteurs d'une valeur de 20
milliards de dollars
8 usines dans un seul endroit
dix mille nouveaux emplois bien payés
sont à environ à 135 milliards de
dollars par année
fabrication la plus sophistiquée du
monde pour produire des puces
électroniques pour vraiment être présent
partout dans les téléphones de
l'internet
ddt qu'un jus de l'avenir qu'on ne
connaît même pas ce n'est que le début
et parle de singles le pdg d'intel voilà
bonjour bonjour patel avez vous qu'on
vous reconnaisse
ac est venu me voir et m'a dit qu'ils
sont prêts à augmenter leur
investissement de 20 milliards à 100
milliards de dollars ce serait
l'investissement industriel le plus
important dans l'histoire d'amérique et
ils n'ont besoin que d'une seule chose
c'est que vous adoptez cette loi alors
n'attendons plus envoyez moi le projet
de loi je vais le signer et nous
pourrons vraiment décollé mais de plus
belle
et vous savez quoi
intel n'est pas seul
on essaie ça quelque chose en amérique
regardez autour de vous et vous allez
voir quelque chose d'incroyable toute
cette fierté qui vient de ses mots
fabbrica numérique la revitalisation de
notre industrie et des entreprises
viennent construire leur usine ici et à
quelques années c'était outre mer voilà
ce qu'a révélé le site folle investir 11
milliards de dollars pour construire des
véhicules électriques et cela crée aux
mails emplois au pays jm c'est le plus
gros investissement de son histoire 7
milliards pour construire des véhicules
électriques et dont 4000 en promulguant
en tout dix nous
pensons à
369 mes nouveaux emplois industriels en
amérique et cela juste l'année dernière
vous savez
grâce à des gens comme doudou m'bodji
vraiment avec tout l'héritage syndicale
de pittsburgh jo jo où êtes vous et
merci
vous êtes un chic type
[Applaudissements]
comme charles band c'est la triste de
loyaux le 10
10 il est temps d'éliminer cette idée de
la ceinture de rouille
on appelait cela la ceinture de rouille
c'était
cette zone industrielle oka d'amérique
et là c'est fini car on voit une
résurgence de notre capacité
industrielle
donc il ya plus de meilleurs salaires
beaucoup de 300 emplois et pourtant
beaucoup de familles ont du mal parce
que l'inflation leur enlève ce surplus
qu'ils ont je le comprends c'est
pourquoi ma première priorité c'est de
maîtriser la montée des prix écoutez
notre économie revenus plus rapidement
qu'on avait ce qu'on avait prévu mais
pendant la pandémie les entreprises
avaient du mal à engager les
travailleurs à cause la pandémie et donc
la production l afssa faiblissait il n'y
avait pas de gens qui construisait ses
poutres qui net qui était nécessaire
pour construire
cela a aussi perturbé les chaînes
d'approvisionnement mondiales
les usines ont fermé et là ça prend plus
de temps pour produire des biens et les
acheminer ou d'entrepôts et en dessous
du magasin et les prix montent regardez
les autos un tiers de toutes les façons
ce à cause des ventes d'automobiles et
avait passé de semi conducteurs pour
construire toutes les autos que les gens
voulaient acheter et imaginer quoi les
prix de les autos ont augmenté de
beaucoup surtout les autos usagées
et donc nous avons un choix
une façon de combattre l'inflation c'est
de faire baisser les salaires et à
[ __ ] et les américains moi je pense
une meilleure idée pour combattre
l'inflation a baissé les coûts et non
pas vous salaires
mais cela veut dire pro 2 et plus de
taux et de semi conducteurs à l'amérique
+ infrastructures plus d'innovation ici
chez nous à l'amérique ou plus de biens
qui se déplace plus rapidement à
meilleur marché en amérique plus
d'emplois où vous pouvez voir un salaire
décent hisser numérique plutôt que
vraiment se fier aux chaînes
d'approvisionnement étrangères sabri
condom tout cela chez nous en amérique
les économistes
la foule de scander us et united states
of america
les économistes appellent cela
l'augmentation de la capacité productive
l'économie moi j'appelle ça bâtir une
meilleure amérique
mon plan visant à combattre l'inflation
va abaisser vos coûts et abaisser le
déficit 17 nobélisé en économie on dit
que mon plein va abaisser les pressions
inflationnistes les grands pdg et je
pense la plupart des américains
soutiennent le plan est aussi le plein
premièrement
réduire le coût des prescriptions
nous payons davantage pour les mêmes
médicaments
produits par la même entreprise flamen
pharmaceutique ici chez nous que tout
autre pays regardez l'insuline un
américain sur dix souffre de diabète en
virginie j'ai rencontré un garçon de 13
ans qui s'appelle josh haut débit soit
l'âge salut joe choix
lui comme son papa ont le diabète de
type 1
ça veut dire qu'ils ont ils ont besoin
d'insuline à tous les jours un swing ça
coûte environ 10 $ par fioles pour
produire
voilà ce que ça coûte aux
pharmaceutiques mais ces entreprises
font payer jusqu'à 30 fois plus cher
j'ai parlé à la mère de joshua mais je
n'ai ce que c'est que de regarder votre
enfant qui a besoin d'insuline pour
rester en vie et ils n'ont aucune idée
comment payer tout cela qu'est ce que
cela fait à votre famille avec dignité
en capacité de regarder votre enfant
dans les yeux d'être parent à la hauteur
de vos propres attentes
pensez-y
moi c'est à ça que je pense vous savez
hier je choisis ce soir mais hier
c'était son anniversaire joyeux
anniversaire bonne fête mon cher
aux jo choix
deux cent mille autres jeunes avec un
diabète de type 1
plafonnons le coup de l'insuline à
transcendera par mois pour que chacun
puisse la seule offrir et qui les
pharmaceutiques vont encore s'en sortent
très bien leur marge bénéficiaire est
vraiment très belle et tant qu'à y être
je sais qu'on a des désaccords là dessus
mais
négocions vraiment une abaissement des
prescriptions des coûts de prescription
sur toute la ligne pour medicare
[Applaudissements]
déjà les vétérans paix - écoutez le plan
de sauvetage l'amérique aide millions de
familles et il sauve deux mille quatre
cent par année pour leurs primes de
santé comblant les cas pour que ses
économies soit permanente
deuxièmement
[Applaudissements]
coupons les coûts de l'énergie plus
famille en moyenne 500 da par année en
combattant les changements climatiques
au front des investissements et des
crises et pau pour que vous puissiez
écologiser votre maison votre entreprise
pour être plus efficace et coûts
énergétiques et cela avec un crédit
d'impôt doublons la production de
l'énergie propre éolienne ou solaire et
vous aurez avec des véhicules
électriques moins cher 80 dollars par
mois de moins de dépenses
[Applaudissements]
troisièmement ce que nous pouvons faire
pour aider les travailleurs c'est de
réduire les coûts des garderies
réduisent et donc le coût des garderies
écouter mes amis
si vous vivez dans une grande ville vous
pouvez payer jusqu'à quatorze mille
dollars par année par enfant pour la
garderie
moi j'étais un père monoparental avec
deux enfants pendant cinq ans mais
j'avais ma fratrie qui les dlc sur ma
mère et des mais les gens ne devraient
pas payer plus que 7% de leur revenu
pour les garderies
[Applaudissements]
mon plein couperet secondes de moitié
pour la plupart des familles
et pourrait aider les parents et inclut
des millions de femmes qui ont quitté la
force de travail pendant pandémique car
elle ne pouvait pas se permettre elle
peut pas se payer les garderies elles
pourront revenir sur le marché du
travail et aider la prospérité je pense
également aux
problèmes qu'on vit avec le coup de
caisse que ce soit les sécher celle des
lots chemin et maternelle tout coacher
selon mon plein quiconque fait moins de
400 mille dollars par année ne va pas
payer un seul sou additionnel en impôts
personne je pourrais me tromper
mais moi je devienne que si on faisait
un sondage ici secret construit tous
d'accord que le système fiscal actuel
n'est pas équitable il nous faut le
réparer
je ne veux punir personne mais soyons
sûrs que les riches et les grandes
sociétés payent leur juste part
écoutez l'année dernière
[Applaudissements]
comme chris kunitz en cap
et
macro grèce ces tags et où nous voulons
du coeur des grandes sociétés
il y a plus de sociétés qui ont leur
siège sa salle ici et après 36 ans je me
pose plein de questions
il devrait tout simplement payer leur
juste part l'année dernière 500
compagnies sur la liste des 500 les plus
riches ont fait 40 milliards en profits
et ont payé 0 $ 1 mais pau fédéraux
c'est pas juste
c'est pourquoi j'ai proposé un taux
d'imposition minimal de 15 % pour les
sociétés et c'est pourquoi dans le g7
est ailleurs
j'ai pu aider il ya 130 pays qui sont
d'accord sur un taux minimal
d'imposition pour les entreprises ne
puissent pas s'enfuir dans un autre
juridiction fiscale pour échapper aux
impôts cela va donner des milliards
c'est pourquoi j'ai tenté de fermer les
échappatoires pour les grains riches
pour qu'il pèse au moins hautain jeunes
enseignants qu'un pompier voilà mon
plein nous allons faire croître
l'économie d'abaisser les coûts pour les
familles mais qu'est ce que nous
attendons allons-y nous savons qu'il
faut apporter des changements bon sens
écoutée
et tant qu'à y être
confirmée donc mes candidats à la
réserve fédérale la réserve fédérale qui
joue un rôle critique dans le combat
contre l'inflation mon plan ne va pas
uniquement à baisser les coûts pour les
familles qui auront le meilleur chance
on va essayer également abaisser le
déficit le gouvernement antérieur n'a
pas seulement fait gonfler le déficit
avec des réductions d'impôts pour les
croirait chez les sociétés la porter à
tête aux agents de surveillance
et pour éviter qu'ils les fonds
d'allégement pandémie qui ne soient pas
gaspillés
où aller cet argent qu'il a dépensé
qu'il a reçu avec mon gouvernement les
agents de surveillance sont de retour et
nous allons poursuivre les criminels qui
ont volé des milliards en argent qui
devait aller aux pme et chalon ce soir
que le ministre de la justice va
maintenant nommer un procureur en chef
pour la fraude pandémique
à écouter
je pense que nous sommes tous d'accord
là-dessus avant la fin de l'année le
déficit sera à montlouis de la moitié de
ce que c'était quand j'ai pris les rênes
du pouvoir le seul président à réduire
le déficit de plus d'un billion de
dollars en une seule année à baisser vos
coups cela veut également dire exiger
plus de compétition je suis un
capitalisme mais le capitalisme sans
compétition ce n'est pas du capitalisme
on s'entend
en fait c'est l'exploitation et cela
fait augmenter les prix
quand les sociétés ne font pas
concurrence leurs profits augmenter vos
prix augmentent
les petites entreprises et les éleveurs
de ruraux sont en difficulté
écoutez vous avez quatre usines de
transformation de la viande c'est tout
vous jouez avec eux ou rien et vous
payer beaucoup plus cher parce qu a pas
de concurrence
regardez avec les transporteurs
maritimes qui font
acheminer les biens pendant la pandémie
un mur aux
moins de 6 ans augmenter de 1000 % ils
ont fait des profits incroyables ce soir
j'annonce que nous allons sévir sur les
entreprises de transport maritime qui
ont une tarification excessive et
abusive et cela touche à la fois les
entreprises comme les consommateurs
américains
je fais quand je pense à wall street qui
commencé à acheter des échasses elle dit
des fois de retraite la qualité va vers
le bas et les coûts augmentent ça c'est
fini medicare va établir des normes plus
élevées plus exigeantes pour les foyers
de retraite pour que nous êtres chers
sont vraiment entre meilleure main nous
allons également réduire le coût pour
que l'économie soit forte nous allons
donner une chance égale aux travailleurs
offrir plus de formation du stade à
prendre si pour qu'il puisse être
engagée sur leurs compétences et non
seulement dans diplôme alors adoptons le
pitch ex zac faisons monter le seuil
minimum acquise dollars de l'heure et
prolongez crédit d'impôt plus avoir plus
que personne ne se retrouve il vit une
famille la pauvreté augmente on les
bourses fédérales pour les collégiens
défavorisés et aussi les collèges noir
ont besoin d'elle est notre première
dame qui travaille à temps plein comme
enseignante
on oublie trop souvent l'importance de
nos collèges communautaires des collèges
techniques alors donc adoptons le croate
quand majorité de travailleurs veulent
former un syndicat on ne devrait pas
pouvoir les bloquer
quand on a baissé d'un travailleur non
construit une économie à partir de
l'intérieur on peut faire quelque chose
qu'on n'a pas fait depuis longtemps en
amérique bâtir une meilleure amérique
pendant plus de deux ans la corrida
était un impact sur chaque décision de
nos vies et la vie de la nation elle
même et je sais que vous êtes fatigué
frustré épuisé
près d'un million de personnes qui sont
assis à la table et qu'ils regardent une
chaise vide devant eux
parce qu'ils ont perdu un être cher et
je sais également ceci en lien avec les
progrès accomplis grâce à votre
résilience grâce aux outils dont on
s'est doté par le congrès ce soir je
peux dire que nous allons de l'avant
avec
toute la sécurité requise hier une
routine quotidienne plus normal
nous avons un tel un nouveau moment un
tournant dans le combat contre la coved
ou les maladies graves sont au niveau de
juillet de l'année dernière il ya pas
longtemps le cdc a émis de nouvelles
directives pour les masquer en vertu de
ces nouvelles lignes directrices la
plupart des gens peuvent se
défaire de leurs masques
marcher librement
respirer l'air pur et bientôt nous
allons traverser le chu un peu partout
grâce à tous les progrès accomplis
depuis un an la coved n'est plus maître
de nos vies je sais que d'aucuns disent
l'importance de vivre avec la coved ce
soir jeudi que nous n'allons jamais
accepter de vivre avec l'arrivée nous à
continuer le combat contre les virus
comme le combat contre toute maladie et
parce que ce virus est en mutation
constante il nous faut rester vigilants
voici quatre idées me qui émane du gros
bon sens premièrement
protégez vous avec les vaccins et les
traitements nous savons à quel point les
vaccins sont efficaces si vous êtes
vacciné et avec la 12e rappel vous avez
le plus haut degré de protection n'ont
jamais abandonné cette idée de vacciner
américaine je sais que les parents
d'enfants de moins de cinq ans ont hâte
de voir l'autorisation de la vaccination
les scientifiques travaillent fort là
dessus et nous serons prêts avec des
vaccins dès que c'est à prouver
nous sommes également prêts avec les
traitements antiviraux si vous attrapez
la coved pfizer offre cette pilule qui
réduit vos chances d'être hospitalisée
de 90%
j'ai commandé plus de pilules que tout
autre pays
elle faisait travaillent jour et nuit
pour coller un million de pilules ce
mois ci est plus du double mois d'après
elle maintenant nous lançons le test tué
l'initiative pour que les gens puissent
être testé dans une pharmacie et s'ils
sont positifs ils reçoivent le pilule
anti viral tout de suite et cela
gratuitement
écoutez
votre système immunitaire est affaibli
voire compromis ou si vous avez une
autre vulnérabilité sous jacente lors
des traitements et des masques de haute
qualité gratuit on ne laisse personne de
rien en ligne en les besoins de
personnes en allant de l'avant et sur
les tests le dépistage il nous avons
rendu des centaines de millions tests
disponibles vous pouvez les commander
gratuitement ils seront livrés à votre
porte si vous avez déjà commander vos
tests soient j'annonce que vous pouvez
aussi
aller chercher d'autres tests allaient à
couver thèse point g au v pour obtenir
d'autres trousses de dépistage de ses
mains il faut se préparer pour les
nouveaux variants depuis un an on s'est
vraiment améliorée dans le signalement
des nouveaux variants et je crois que
nous pourrons en arriver à un vaccin
dans les cent jours après la découverte
si nous obtenons les fonds nécessaires
nous aurons vraiment un inventaire de
tests de masse et de plus près je ne
peux pas promettre qu'il n'y aura pas de
nouveaux variants mais je puis vous
promettre que nous ferons tout ce que
nous pouvons au gouvernement pour
maîtriser ce nouveau variant dès qu'il
se pointe le nez mesdames et messieurs
heureusement
on peut mettre fin à la fermeture des
écoles et des commerces on a tous les
outils à la disposition de l'amérique et
les grains temps qu'on revienne au
travail et qu'on remplisse son centre
ville les gens qui travaillent à la
maison peuvent se sentir en sécurité en
revenant au bureau nous faisons aussi au
gouvernement fédéral d'ailleurs la très
grande majorité des fonctionnaires de
fédérale peuvent encore se vend en faire
revenir au travail nous écoles ont
ouvert leurs portes il faut maintenir
cette situation telle qu'elle est nos
enfants ont besoin dans la salle de
classe avec d'autres jeunes avec leurs
profs devant eux en présentiel
j'aime les fois avec 75 % des adultes
vaccinés et
les hospitalisations en chute de 77% la
plupart des maquettes peuvent retirer le
masque retourner au travail retourner en
salle de classe et aller de l'avant avec
leur vie nous l'avons réussie parce que
nous avons faire des vaccins gratuit des
traitements des tests et les masques
mais sûr cela coûte de l'argent alors
cela ne vous surprendra guère que
j'aimerais bien vous revoir et j'ai
envoyé une demande au congrès la très
grande majorité des américains se sont
servis de ces outils et il voudrait
peut-être s'en resservir alors j'attends
du congrès qu'ils adoptent rapidement ce
projet de loi première 80 nous allons
continuer d'attaquer le monde nous avons
envoyé 475 millions de vaccins dans 112
différents payer plus que toute autre
nation sur la planète entière et nous
n'arrêtons pas au loup est de là on ne
peut pas érigé une muraille pour
échapper à un nouveau variant mais le
vaccin fait muraille vous avez on à
temps perdu avec la coved
du temps à passer
entre nous et bien sûr combien de vies
perdues
peut-être prenons un moment pour faire
un examen de conscience
arrêtons de voir la coved comme une
scission partisane
non si ce qu'est ce que c'est une
maladie affreuse et ross
prêtons de se voir un ennemi voyons-nous
comme le sont réellement des
compatriotes des amériques est entre eux
les américains de bonne foi
oui
on ne peut pas vraiment affecté tous les
clivages du passé
mais on peut quand même changer l'avenir
sur la corvée des doutes en jeu il faut
faire front commun tout récemment je me
suis rendu à la police de new york
quelques jours après les funérailles des
policiers wilber mora et jason rivera
ils régissent l l'appel au 9-1-1 quand
un homme est abattu avec une arme volée
le policier mort à 27 ans le fils et
rivera avait deux ans tous les deux d
aymeric est d'origine dominicaine qui
ont grandi dans les mêmes rues et ont
décidé de patrouiller leur propre rue
d'enfance comme policier j'ai parlé avec
leur famille et je leur ai dit que nous
étions en betty à tout jamais devant le
sacrifice et qui nous allions continuer
cette mission de rétablir la confiance
la sécurité dans chaque communauté
écoutez j'ai travaillé avec vous depuis
longtemps sur ces enjeux et je sais ce
qui fonctionne
investir dans les policiers
communautaires le travail de prévention
les policiers qui connaissent leur
quartier qui l'arborent et qui vraiment
le portent dans leur coeur qui
choisissent leur quartier et qui
travaille à rétablir la confiance la
sécurité n'abandonnons pas nos rues
il ne faut pas choisir entre la sécurité
et la justice et l'égalité c'est
pourquoi pour protéger les communautés
rétablir la confiance je veux proposer
qu'on puisse avoir plus de redevabilité
pendant les forces de l'ordre c'est
pourquoi je propose des caméras
corporelle et combani certaines prises
de
pour maîtriser les suspects qui risque
de les tuer
il ya des stratégies prouver c'est
pourquoi le plan de sauvetage l'amérique
offre 350 millions aux villes avec des
stratégies de sur la violence
communautaire et de casser le cycle de
la violence et des traumatismes d'offrir
aux jeunes de l'espoir on devrait tous
d'accord ce n'est pas une idée de des
finances et la police non ce de financer
la police
oui mieux les financer
mais sinon c'est leur offrir des
ressources de la formation afin qu'ils
puissent mieux protéger leur communauté
je demande aux démocrates et aux
républicains
adopter mon budget pour protéger nos
quartiers
je ferai tout pour
freiner le trafic d armes et ses hommes
est possible a trait à retracer qu'on
achète en ligne et qui ont aucun numéro
de série et qu'on peut pas tracy
il faut absolument adopter l'examen des
antécédents
pourquoi quelqu'un sur la liste
terroriste est en mesure de s'acheter
une arme à feu pourquoi dites moi
pourquoi
mesdames et messieurs
il faut interdire les armes d'assaut
avec des chargeurs jusqu'à 100
projectiles
pensez vous que les chevreuils portent
des gilets pare balles
il faut que les manufacturiers de
l'amérique parce qu'il ya une loi qui
les protègent n'est ce pas on ne peut
pas les poursuivre en justice
si on l'avait fait avec les producteurs
de tabac
je n'ai pas du tout une question du
second d'amendements cela c'est pour
sauver des vies leur droit le plus
fondamental en amérique c'est le droit
de voter et qu'on puisse
à faire entendre notre voix et on est en
train de s'en prendre dans un état pré
lot de nouvelles lois ont été
promulguées non seulement pour éliminer
le vote mais pour subvertir des
élections entière c'est impossible ça ce
soir j'avais cédant à adopter le freedom
to voga acteurs
et aussi adopté le john rawlings actes
et tant qu'à y être adopté le disque
rose que les américains sachent qui est
en train de financer nos élections
ce soir j'aimerais en aurait quelqu'un
qui a dévoué toute sa vie au pays le
juge stephen breyer un vétéran
universitaires constituent elles un juge
qui prend sa retraite de la cour suprême
monsieur le juge merci de votre service
merci merci merci
plus je le dis du fond du coeur levé
vous
merci
nous savons tous et toutes
quelle que soit l'idéologie
unité responsabilité constitutionnelle
est plus sérieuse un président aux etats
unis c'est de nommer quelqu'un
sur le bain de la cour suprême des etats
unis
et comme je lé fais il ya quatre jours
je me mets la juge de la cour d'appel
catane vibrant jackson
une de nos meilleurs juristes qui va
s'inspirer du legs du juge brailleurs
et
incarner l'excellence
elle fait de la pratique privée elle a
été procureur également pour l'état et
elle vient d'une famille de policiers
d'enseignants elle cherche le consensus
dès sa nomination elle a reçu beaucoup
de soutien de la fraternité des
policiers aidés à ses juges nommés à la
fois par les démocrates comme les
républicains
écoutez
pour avancer et faire avancer la liberté
la justice il nous faut quand même
réparer le saint des migrations et
sécuriser la frontière
et comme vous pouvez l'imaginer on peut
faire les deux à la frontière on
installe et nouvelles technologies comme
des scanneurs de pointe pour mieux
détecter les narcotiques il ya des
patrouilles conjointes avec les
mexicains et guatémaltèques pour
attraper les trafiquants nous avons des
juges spécialisés
pour que les familles qui fuient la
persécution différences peuvent être
acceptées plus rapidement et qu'on
puisse retourner les autres nous sommes
en train d'obtenir un engagement et des
partenaires en amérique centrale et il
amène sud pour qu'ils puissent avoir une
mère ses critères propres frontières et
garder les réfugiés on peut tout cela on
peut le faire tout ça mais sur tout en
protégeant le flambeau de la liberté qui
a amené des générations du maigrin si on
veut permettre aux gamers de devenir
citoyens ceux qui ont un statut
temporaire des travailleurs agricoles
des travers essentiel il faut réviser
les lois pour les entreprises puissent
avoir les travailleurs dont ils ont
besoin la famille n'atteint pas des dc
lipodrainer ce n'est pas uniquement la
bonne chose c'est vraiment intelligent
simple économique c'est pourquoi la
réforme de l'immigration et soutenu par
les syndicats les gens religieux et même
un chantre commerce des états-unis alors
réussissons le kun ça pour tout
écouter
le fait avancer la liberté la justice
exige également de nous qu'on protège
les droits des femmes
le droit constitutionnel de vos
besoins est vraiment sous attaque le
droit à l'avortement est menacée on
venait glavin et n'ont pas reculé il
faut protéger l'accès au sens à l'aso
soins de santé il faut continuer à
protéger la santé maternelle et
néonatale pour toutes les femmes et
protéger le droit des femmes de choisir
et pour
américain lgbt qu plus
adoptons la loi mais parti de l'égalité
il y a énormément de loi des taxes sont
en train de prendre pour cible les
familles transgenres c'est une erreur
c'est inacceptable j'ai vu l'année
dernière l'importance de tandt a mais
vous avez des transgenres parce que je
veux que chaque américain chaque
américaine fut sa thèse sur potentiel
important sel quand même donné par dieu
lui-même à chaque être humain
et comme je viens de prouver
on n'est pas toujours d'accord
mais on est d'accord sont bien plus de
choses qu'on est près de reconnaître moi
j'ai saigné 80 loi mais par titre je les
ai premier gain pour empêcher les
fermetures devant moment pour protéger
les américains d'ascendance asiatique et
des crimes haineux la réforme la justice
militaire et mais sûre nous allons
renforcer la loi contre la violence
faite aux femmes que j'ai moi même
rédigé il y à quoi trois décennies il
est important pour nous
montrer la nation tout entière qu'on
peut se rassembler et riz sur de grandes
choses alors ce soir j'offre comment
dire des priorités pour nous unir quatre
grands dossiers premièrement l'épidémie
des opioïdes
l'épidémie des opiacés il faut réussir y
attendent qu'on peut faire augmenter les
financements pour la prévention pour le
traitement pour la réduction des torts
et la récupération
il y a des règles sur aisne et qu'il
faut changer
arrêtons cette circulation des
médicaments il est cet allant chercher
les trafiquants et c'est vous souffrez
de dépendance d'une toxicomanie sachez
que vous n'êtes pas seuls moi je crois à
la guérison et je célèbre level 3
millions d'américains qui sont par
établissement maintenant deuxièmement
parlons de la santé mentale surtout
parmi nos enfants dont les vies
l'éducation était vraiment tellement
perturbé le plan de sauvetage l'amérique
a donné de l'argent pour un gage de plus
d'enseignants pour que les jeunes
puissent rattraper leur apprentissage
jégu j'exhorte chaque parent de
s'assurer que votre école le fasse ils
ont l'argent nous pouvons tous faire
notre part alors offrez vous comme
tuteur comme motors les enfants avaient
du mal avant la pandémie l'harcèlement
la violence est romain tous les torts
des médias sociaux tels que google est
parmi nous ce soir l'a bien montré il
nous faut tenir les médias sociaux
redevable pour cette expérience
nationale qui
impose à nos enfants pour gagner plus de
profits
écoutez
il est merci je remercie et je dis merci
à francis merci de votre courage madame
art hogan
il est temps de renforcer la protection
des vies privées et interdire la
publicité qui cible les enfants exiger
des grandes compagnies technologiques
qu'ils arrêtent le recueillir des
données personnelles sur nos propres
enfants et
offrant à tous les américains et
services en santé mentale dont elles ont
besoin de plus de gens qui peuvent aller
chercher de l'aide et de la parité
totale enclin
compréhension de l'importance à santé
mentale et physique dans nos pleins
d'assurance santé
afin qu'ils s'adaptent le troisième
volet de ses priorités c'est de soutenir
nos vétérans
les vétérans seller chez même de ce pays
ils sont les meilleurs parmi nous
j'ai toujours cru que
nous avons une obligation sacrée envers
ceux qu'on envoie à la guerre pour qu'on
s'occupe d'eux et de leur famille à leur
tour mon roman offre une aide pour la
formation l'emploi le chemin et
maintenant nous aidons les vétérans
défavorisés à se libérer leurs dettes et
nous troupes en irak et en afghanistan
qui ont fait face attendant j'ai un set
est de respirer ces
émanations toxiques
de ces grands trous d'incinération des
déchets de bases militaires
cette décélération des déchets médicaux
militaires du carburant de rester tout
ça était respirer au retour
les meilleurs parmi nous ces combattants
ne sont plus les mêmes les maux de tête
des étourdissements des engourdissements
un cancer qui les met directement dans
la tombe
une tombe avec un drapeau d'accord
mais quand même un de ses soldats
s'étaient mon propre fils les majors
bobl je ne suis peut être sûr si ce site
d'incarcération pardon de décélération a
contribué à son cancer du cerveau en
irak je ne peux pas être sûr de cela ou
les maladies connues par tant d'autres
troupes mais je m'engage à trouver tout
ce que nous pouvons découvrir je
m'engage aux familles militaires telles
que celles de daniel robinson de ohio
la veuve du sergent qui il était mais un
soldat de la garde nationale
ambulanciers médical militaire au kosovo
en irak proche de bagdad et il y avait 6
et d'incinération des déchets la
grandeur du terrain de football
et puis là daniel
sa veuve est parmi nous ce soir il
adorait aller au match de football de
l'université ohio state
adorait jouer avec les lego avec leur
fille mais le cancer données due à une
exposition à ces sites d'incinération a
détruit son corps ravagé ses poumons
daniel dit que kif s'est battu jusqu'à
la fin il ne savait pas comment arrêter
elle non plus ne savais pas dans sa
douleur à la trouver quand même
cette exigence que nous fassions mieux
ce soir daniel nous te promettons
le ministère des anciens combattants est
en train d'établir de nouveaux liens
entre l'exposition aux toxines et les
maladies pour aider ces vétérans ce soir
les annonces que nous allons justement
offrir de l'aide pour les anciens
combattants issus de neuf cancers
respiratoires et je
veux qu'ils famille offre enfin les
prestations et tout las
le budget nécessaire pour ce prix de
leur santé car c'est ce qu'ils méritent
quand on voit comme une vétérans ont été
dévastés par l'exposition aux toxines de
nos propres sites d'incinération 4ème en
mettant fin au cancer tel que nous le
connaissons ses personnels vous savez
c'est vraiment personnel pour moi hadj
elecam à la et combien d'entre vous
combien d'entre vous avez perdu
quelqu'un que vous aimiez
quelqu'un de votre famille quelqu'un de
proche le cancer est la deuxième cause
de mortalité
seulement derrière lehman dit
cardiovasculaires le mois dernier j'ai
annoncé le plein de
financer le programme de recherche
cancer nous voulons coupé de 50 % le
taux de mortalité du cancer sur 25 ans
transformant les cancers de
maladies mortelles vers des maladies
chroniques plus août et pour les
passants pour les familles et pour s'y
rendre j'appelle justement à mes
congressistes de financer ce que
j'appelle la repas c'est la hache et les
projets de recherche avancée sur la
santé s'est fondé sur le darpa de ce
ministre de la défense et les projets de
darpa emmener ou gps à l'internet et
combien d'autres innovations
technologiques
et tout cela
c'est que nous aurons seul objectif d'en
arriver à des percées en cancer
alzheimer dans le diabète est davantage
donc notre priorité pour fédérer la
nation nous pourrit sur le coup c'est à
notre portée
et je ne vois vraiment aucun volet
partisans cela mes chers compatriotes
ce soir
car nous sommes réunis dans cet endroit
sacré la citadelle de notre démocratie
dans ce capital
génération après génération
les américains ont débattu des grands
enjeux de leur époque
parmi deux grands conflits on a conclu
beaucoup nous sommes battus pour la
liberté
nous avons vécu le totalitarisme et la
terreur on a bâti la nation la plus
prospère la plus libre est la plus forte
dans l'histoire de la planète l'heure
est venue
c'est notre moment de responsabilité
c'est le test de notre résolution de
conscience de l'histoire elle même
c'est en ce moment que notre caractère
et forger
notre objectif se retrouvent que notre
avenir se forge
moi je connais bien cette nation nous
serons à la hauteur de ce défi
l'histoire protéger la liberté
élargir les kits et les perspectives
d'avenir nous allons sauver la
démocratie
même si ses tantes et du site je suis
plus optimiste sur l'amérique
aujourd'hui que toute ma vie parce que
je vois l'avenir qui est à notre portée
parce que je sais qu'il n'y a rien que
nous ne pouvons pas réussir nous sommes
la seule nation sur la terre qui a
toujours pu transformer chaque crise en
une perspective de succès la seule
nation qui peut être défini par un seul
mot les possibles alors ce soir en outre
2 5 45e anniversaire nationale je suis
venu vous va vous parler de l'état de
l'union et mon rapport et ceci c'est que
l'état l'union et karnas force parce que
vous le peuple américain vous incarnez
la force
nous sommes plus forts aujourd'hui
nous sommes plus forts aujourd'hui qu'on
l'était il ya un homme
et nous serons encore plus forts dans un
an que nous le sommes aujourd'hui
ceci est notre moment pour surmonter les
défis de notre époque et nous allons
réussir comme un seul peuple une
amérique les états unis d'amérique
que dieu vous bénisse tous et toutes et
que dieu bénisse et protège nos troupes
merci allez-y foncez
premier discours de joe budden premier
discours de l'état de l'union un an
après son entrée en fonction et il dit
l'amérique est plus forte maintenant
qu'elles ne l'étaient il ya un an elle
sera encore plus forte dans un an ce
discours qui prend des allures ma foi de
programme électoral un programme de
justice sociale il attaqué de front la
question de la guerre en ukraine et
poutine évidemment je vous présente à
nouveau mes invités pour décrypter ce
discours le temps le contenu alors
valérie beaudouin julien tourreille et
daniel marié politologue en forêt de
bonsoir à vous trois à nouveau donné le
mariage a commencé avec vous puisque on
dit généralement qu'un discours de
l'état de l'union c'est pour vraiment
décrire comment va la mairie comment
vont les états unis à tous les niveaux
et
est-ce que brydon a dit aux américains
ce qu'ils voulaient entendre
ce que les américains ou les rotors
ouais bah ajouté il ya des défections
dans le camp baden chez les jeunes chez
les minutes minorités raciales et ce
niveau là je pense que oui parce que il
a parlé des sujets qui concernent les
jeunes les changements climatiques le
droit de voir protection des droits des
minorités raciales
je pense que oui il est allé chercher
italie parfois il a tenté d'aller
chercher ses clientèles électorales est
ce que vont écouter est ce qu'elles ont
écouté ça c'est une autre question
est y avait de la deûle enthousiasme de
l'espoir quand un discours différent de
ce qu'on entend qu'on a entendu deux
dernières années également mais dans les
dernières années on n'avait pas le même
contexte à la fois de sortie de pandémie
et d'entrer en guerre bons peuvent des
états unis mais quand même on est
tellement impliqué et ça donnait un
moment très rare de solidarité ou d'un
côté comme de l'autre on applaudissait
on sentait qu'on était derrière le
peuple ukrainien ont été derrière aussi
le gouvernement et joe biden l'a dit il
on partait nous diviser même ici à la
maison congrès pensé qu'on allait être
divisé on ne l'est pas même chose pour
les alliés donc si j'ai trouvé que c'est
lé moment est très fort entre autres
dans son discours alors vous parlez de
l'ukraine évidemment on va écouter
l'extrait et je vais à la voûte suite
après julien tourreille on écoute cet
extrait de dubaï 2,9 sur la grande crise
mais cela bouge tes de nombreux efforts
de diplomatie il pensait que l'occident
et le temps ne réagirait pas ils
pensaient qu'ils pouvaient nous diviser
nous aidez nous crie vie ici chez nous
il pensait qu' il pouvait aussi divisé
l'europe mais il a fait une erreur nous
sommes prêts nous sommes unis
il n'a aucune idée de ce qui l'attend le
rouble a déjà perdu 30% de sa valeur
40% de valeur boursière perdue et la
bourse est toujours fermé l'économie
russe est un trait de chanceler et
poutine est le seul qui est responsable
alors julien tour est un moment fort de
ce discours qui d'entrée de jeu pour le
président lui permettait d'attaqué
poutine et de la et de préciser cette
guerre économique oui tout à fait et ça
donnait une petite originalité à à la
forme de ce discours en d'habitude un
président des états unis lorsqu'ils
commencent discours sur l'état de
l'union il commence par cette formule
traditionnelle que j'ai le plaisir de
vous reporter que cet état d'union et
fort il a commencé par la situation en
ukraine évidemment le contexte
l'imposé si je puis dire et il a terminé
son discours par cette formule
habituelle donc avait une petite
originalité il a été très ferme bon on
s'y attendait
quant à l'unité à la détermination des
états unis à combattre l'agression menée
par vladimir poutine en ukraine mais il
n'en demeure pas moins que ce discours
sur l'état de l'union était avant tout
un discours de campagne électorale pour
mobiliser les démocrates en vue des
élections de mi mandat de novembre
prochain et peut-être qu'à cet égard on
retiendra d'abord que c'était un
discours de campagne destinée à la
population américaine à la politique
intérieure avant tout d'être un discours
marquant sur les questions de politique
étrangère et des relations
internationales pour vous az vous êtes
là je crois on vous a
au bout oui à z pour vous qu'est ce que
vous retenez essentiellement de ce
discours ce soit sur le ton le contenu
ou les thèmes préférés je moi je retiens
entre qu'une chose il en position à
l'expression mens et plein mon plan il a
un plan un plan qu'il propose aux
américains est la question que je
lançais aux invités pendant que vous
étiez peut-être téléjournal est-ce qu'il
a 12 et briquets ce que les américains
voulaient entendre les leurs at il donné
de l'espoir pour l'avenir
ça certainement qu'on le saura lors des
élections de mi mandat s'il a vraiment
passé le test est ce que je peux vous
dire anne marie c'est qu'on n'a jamais
vue en tout cas moi j'ai jamais vu joe
biden aussi énergétique aussi combatif
la danse on dans son discours il a
commencé avec l'ukraine et la terminer
en disant google comme s'ils allaient
aller attraper vladimir poutine si vous
voulez il a vraiment il était vraiment
très convaincant si vous voulez en
disant que voilà c'est la démocratie
contre la contre l'autocratie il est dit
que la liberté allait triompher sur la
tyrannie c'était quand même des mots
extrêmement forts qu'ils avaient besoin
évidemment des alliances qu'il a
travaillé extrêmement fort là dessus
donc encore une fois comme vous le dites
c'était son plan de parler à l'union
européenne et vous savez joe biden a été
sénateur pendant plus de trente ans donc
c'est un homme de compromis qui a
toujours cette habitude de faire des
alliances que ce soit avec des
républicains au congrès et là évidemment
c'était avec l'union européenne avec
l'otan également sur sur l'économie il a
parlé de son plan sur l'infrastructure
encore une fois il est dit que c'était
son plan et c'est vrai que c'était un
peu à saveur électorale à et disait que
l'amérique est forte quand elle est unie
il a dit que son plan sur
l'infrastructure et ben ils vont pouvoir
les états unis vont pouvoir
compétitionner avec la chine que plus de
5000 km de routes vont être réparées
1500 pont il a également parlé de
l'inflation en disant qu'il faut arrêter
de dépendre sur les chaînes
d'approvisionnement qu'en fait on l'a vu
avec la pandémie la toux le blocage qui
a eu faut absolument créer des produits
américains c'est extrêmement important
il est dit que pour combattre
l'inflation il fallait pas réduire les
salaires mais réduire les coûts et
augmenter les salaires donc il avait
quand même des formules assez
intéressante durant son discours pour
rassurer les américains pour évidemment
on va voir lors des prochaines élections
de mi mandat si ça sera marché mais ce
qu'il essayait de dire aujourd'hui ce
soir aux américains c'est qu'ils étaient
en meilleure posture qu'il ya un an que
la pandémie est plutôt derrière nous
maintenant on l'a vu au congrès personne
ne portait de masques il a fait son
discours il avait pas de masque on
sentait vraiment qu'on était un peu dans
une ère post pandémique il a dit qu'il a
créé plus de six millions d'emplois dont
il a parlé énormément de c est qu il a
également parlé de son plan bio de bach
belle sur les réformes sociales à quel
point il était importante pour les
américains il a parlé d'environnement il
a aussi parlé ça c'est une chose des
républicains l'ont énormément critiqué
en fait depuis qu'il est là il ya
l'inflation le taux de criminalité a
augmenté la pandémie on ne s'en est pas
vraiment sorti et là il a parlé du taux
de criminalité observer quelques
semaines il était à new york justement
aux deux policiers avaient été tuées et
il a dit que voilà il va vraiment
falloir faire quelque chose les taux de
criminalité est deux fois plus important
dans la ville de new york dont il a dit
qu'il ne faut pas arrêter de financer la
police le contraire de la finance et mes
deux peut-être mieux la forme et pour
répondre justement à cette hausse de
criminalité donc il a touché un peu à
tout on va voir s'il va silva avoir
l'aval des américains en tout cas il a
reçu beaucoup d'ovations durant ce
discours ou et des innovations à une
reprise ou deux peut-être des huées
valérie
et parce que les républicains ne l'ont
pas suivi sur toutes ses promesses
est-ce qu'il a rassemblé sur l'ukraine
il a rassemblé sur l'immigration
notamment oui parce qu'ils sont abonnés
serment sur la santé ou les programmes
de santé maternelle et d'autres non
toutes les réformes sociales les grandes
réformes et son plan b le bakbasel qu'il
veut compléter on sentait pas du tout
d'unités en fait du congrès c'était
vraiment du côté des démocrates parce
que des choses qui semblent peut-être
normal ici pour nous au canada comme les
garderies qui est pas trop dispendieuse
les services de garde les congés de
maternité il apparut la maternelle
quatre ans donc des sujets qui devraient
peut-être réunir les américains que les
familles la classe moyenne mais on
sentait qu'il y avait une unité d'un
côté seulement elle allait chercher
quand même des thèmes pour aller
peut-être chercher des votes
d'indépendants aller chercher quelques
républicains ça va être difficile à
faire mais quand par exemple il parlait
de la criminalité comme on vient de le
mentionner andrée qu'il fallait avoir ce
balancier entre cette justice sociale
mais de l'autre côté vraiment s'assurer
que ce soit sécuritaire pour les
américains et d'autres moments aussi on
de santé on a senti une unité qu'on
parlait des vétérans qu'on parlait aussi
de l'insuline du prix des médicaments ça
c'est quand même quelque chose qui des
deux côtés est une priorité le pour
autant les républicains qui est des mac
et pour vous donner le mariage y at-il
dans les thèmes abordés des sujets qui
risquent de l'aider qu'une chance de
l'aider de région éventuellement parce
que par exemple le prix des médicaments
quand il veut mettre au pas les
compagnies pharmaceutiques mette un
plafond sur le prix de l'insuline pour
les diabétiques et qu'il veut à voir
introduire d'autres mesures à caractère
social
alors écoutez moi ça m'a surpris qu'il
parle de sol une part de ça comme de
partitions plat parce que pendant cinq
mois il a négocié avec les sénateurs
mansion et cinéma et ces négociations se
sont mal terminées et ça fait partie des
difficultés qu'il a avec l'opinion
publique parce qu'il est fini au public
a vu que ça piétine qui ne mange pas et
finalement que ça donne pas de résultats
ces choses là il a ramené ça et je me
demandais quand il parlait de ça et ce
qui là est ce que monsieur machin est ce
que madame cinéma ont approuvé le disco
j'imagine que non mais alors quelles
sont les perspectives ou des chances
d'adoption de ces mesures au résultat de
ce qui s'est passé dans les mois
précédents ces cétacés très faibles
alors ça m'a beaucoup surpris qu'il
parle beaucoup de ça une autre chose que
je voudrais souligner ses katas one doit
s'inquiéter un peu oui parce que il ya
beaucoup de saveurs protectionnistes
heures ce discours on parle de buy
american ont pas ou que dassier des
garde fous sur les autoroutes seraient
produits aux états-unis le canada est un
exportateur important d'acier au canada
aux états unis exportent de la cie aux
états unis etc alors il ya de 7 server
protectionnistes qui bon on attend
souvent dans les discours mais peut-être
que cette fois ci ce sera
impliqué avec plus de fermeté que l'an
passé parce que joe budden cherche veut
neymar se présenter comme jo explique
celui qui va enfin renoué renouveler le
les industries aux états unis il veut
s'il voulait voler un sujet qui me suis
trompé avait fauché alors
j'imagine qu'on s'inquiète un peu oui
mais je m'agite parce qu'elle a un
moment fort du discours daniel c'est que
le concluait ce passage sur l'économie
let's make it in america et sa
scandaient ue et cis est alors vers un
fruit lan a dû avoir les oreilles
ça a dû lui brûler un peu dans les
oreilles n'est ce pas alors est-ce qu'il
a été quand même à rassembleur à z parce
que sur cet élément là sur le sol
infrastructures en ignorant les 6500
autoroute à refaire les 1500 pont et est
ce qu'il a et sur les deux sens sur
certains autres points ce qu'il a réussi
à rassembler parce qu'il se présente
très intéressant oui ça va être
intéressant de marie devoir céder dans
les sondages il est presque en chute
libre la corse ce matin washington post
disait qu'il était trotte 55% des
américains le désapprouver comme comme
président en seulement 35 % l'appui et
même que 59 % affirment qu'il n'est pas
complètement là il a 79 ans il est un
peu trop lent enfin il mais il est
extrêmement critique et sur ce plan-là
donc ce soir il a un peu essayé de faire
taire ces sondages d'un en étant
extrêmement combatif et convaincant
c'est évident que sur pour les
américains ce qui compte c'est un leurre
portefeuille donc s'il réussit à réduire
l'inflation le coût de la vie ça va être
intéressant pour les américains
évidemment la question de la santé
l'accès l'accessibilité aux soins de
santé ça aussi ce sont des questions
extrêmement importante pour la z pour
les américains donc certainement qui va
avoir un autre sondage dadis et de d'ici
demain voir un peu comment il a comment
il a passé le test ce soir et il voudra
raz-de-marée c'est par dont on pouvait
voir anne marie quand même qu'à certains
moments et justement durant son discours
il y avait un mitch mcconnell vous savez
le sénateur le leader des sénateurs
républicains qui vrai qu'ils avaient
vraiment l'air triste fâché on a vu
aussi un plan de coupe de tête cloud le
sénateur du texas même mine aussi donc
c'est sûr qu'il ne fait pas de l'aude
une fois qu comme risquées sur
l'immigration cloud 7 12 à la pause une
fois sur l'immigration la graciant ont
roulé fait est-ce que l'américain reste
flou plane est-ce que ça a des chances
d'aller de l'avant daniel marié
banier
des développements nouveaux entre
machines cinéma et le l'ensemble du
sénat démocratique ce n'est de maquettes
des démocrates au sénat non non je ne
vois pas très bien ce qui ce qui offrait
des bouches il à faire 4 ce projet de
loi a été présenté
il a été mal présentée il a été présenté
du point de vue du jeu des sommes des
crédits publics qui étaient pour être
investi sur 10 ha et ça s'essouffle et
aux états unis yann ambiguïté de dell
d'opinion publique alors les américains
car ils sont avocats n'en discute sur le
plan philosophique ils sont en faveur
d'un état petit un essai de rôle très
limité pour d'autres termes quand on
discute de choses sur le plan très
opérationnelle très concret il tant les
américains être libérés alors il y avait
ciblé des mesures des sondages qui
montraient que les mesures si on les
définit c'est l'une parle autour de
façon concrète avait un soutien
populaire mais la science et aux gens ça
va coûter 350 de temps en temps se rend
alors dans sa seconde lice à iris ce
conservatisme et philosophiques alors le
projet doit été mal présentée parce
qu'ils étaient présentés du point de vue
de ses coûts financiers et ensuite comme
en chine a commencé à se poser à mon
avis pas toujours de bonne foi en tout
cas la gauche à négocier avec lui on
négocier des prix à la baisse ou de
coûts à la baisse mais au fait ça de
façon un peu
malhonnête parce que ce qu'on faisait
ses comptes on disait on va faire
cependant pense pas son design mais sur
cinq ans sur 3 ha et mancini n'est pas
fou il sait très bien que si on commence
à donner des bénéfices trojan dans trois
ans dans cinq cas il va y avoir une
pression politique pour d'erreur
conduire alors ça arrive je n'ai pas
vraiment de deux coups de son point de
vue alors elle l'est il ya eu des
erreurs de ce point de vue là et là je
sais pas très bien comment les deux
condamnés le caucus démocrate et
monsieur benoît sibra pour contourner
cette évolution ou neutraliser
l'opposition de machines et de cinéma et
julien tourreille ont fait d'aller loin
le mentionnait il ya un instant il ya
des propositions qui sont faites qu'il
paraît six au canada tout à fait naturel
au québec également quand on pensait
qu'au service de garde mais ce qui vous
est ce que vous avez retenu je crois
d'internautes et toute la relation avec
la chine la compil la compétition la
compétitivité avec la chine c'est un
grand défi ce pur pour baden oui il
aborde toujours la question des
infrastructures de l'investissement pour
améliorer que ce soit les routes les
connexions internet pour améliorer
l'éducation la formation afin d'avoir
des emplois bien rémunérés dans
l'économie de l'avenir il y toujours ce
programme joe biden ces questions de
politique intérieure à la compétition
avec la chine systématiquement depuis
qu'il était en campagne électorale au
cours de sa première année à la maison
blanche c'est peut-être pour essayer de
montrer week c'est important pour
l'économie américaine pour les citoyens
américains et donc incité peut-être les
partenaires républicains et les quelques
démocrates qui serait récalcitrants à
financer ce type de programme
d'embarquer là dedans mais il sait aussi
pour montrer que il faut mener cette
compétition avec le rival stratégique à
long terme que des états unis qui est la
chine et là c'est intéressant parce
qu'il dévie pas finalement bayh dole
malgré la crise en ukraine qui le force
à beaucoup parler et de l'ukraine et de
vladimir poutine on sait que l'une des
priorités de la politique étrangère des
états unis on sait comment organiser la
relation à venir avec la chine et sur ce
don qui fait le lien entre la politique
entre la politique internationale des
états unis c'est assez intéressant était
un sens d'autant que on vient de
remettre un communiqué de l'ambassade
russe au canada et je traduis une seule
ligne on dénonce la propagande
occidentale à la manière de guembeul qui
était le ministre la propagande de
hitler
on peut pas suffire si tu écris ton le
public au canada doit comprendre seule
la vérité est ailleurs les crimes contre
l'humanité les violations
internationales sont faites par les
forces du crânienne et je fais le lien
j'ai ce que vous disiez parce que dans
le fond tout le conflit avec l'ukraine
ça met en scène aussi les relations avec
la chine suit pas si vous voulez
intervenir là dessus à nouveau julien
oui on aurait pu enfin quand joe biden
est arrivé à la présidence qu'il a dit
qu'il voulait replacer les états unis à
la tête de cette coalition des
démocraties pour lutter contre les
régimes autoritaires il pensait
évidemment à la chine et quelques jours
avant le début des jeux olympiques odeo
moment du début des jeux olympiques ils
pouvaient rajouter cette alliance
éternelle illimité noué entre vladimir
poutine et eksi jean ping bon là les
propos dans vous faites état montre que
le fossé est majeur cette obsession de
des références à l'allemagne nazie du
côté russe laisse sont tout pantois et
ce ne seront pas les bonnes personnes
qui vivent dans une réalité parallèle
surtout qu'ils ont bombardé aujourd'hui
tout près de la tour de télévision
mémorial de l'holocauste pour rire en
ukraine il est tendu mais juifs qui sont
morts en 1941 bombardent et attaquent et
paraît clair il reste 20 secondes chacun
le mot de la fin d'abord valérie ensuite
daniel et az oui bon on le mentionnait
un peu tout à l'heure là mais il va
falloir trouver la façon de réconcilier
ce désir des américains est de parler de
l'ukraine lc désire aussi de démontrer
qu'on veut des sanctions économiques
mais que joe biden ça transparaît pas
dans les sondages pour l'instant sans
que l'opinion publique est derrière ces
mesures là mais quel finalement et il
manquait le petit bout de chemin marié
en secondes
nonobstant de napster discours juste que
nous venons d'entendre donc vous avez
auquel vous avez fait référence la
russie a perdu le contrôle sur l'image
de cette guerre et ses sept jours ben
laden qui a le contrôle et d'autres
contrôles sur l'image de ce qu'elle est
ce cette image
merci restent seconds à m
très rapidement la chine regarde ce qui
se passe en ukraine parce qu'évidemment
la chine la c ie sur taïwan c'est
extrêmement important ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en ukraine merci à tous les
quatre ces deux là dessus qu'on se les
finales messieurs je donne rendez-vous à
24,5 demain 19h bonne soirée
[Musique]